what else are you working on right now
obviously the tour is going on so are
you prepping like are you recording on
the road you got the yeah yeah on the
tour bus in the hotel room I'm working
on my next um that [ __ ] called Lucy kill
damn fan drop project with Martin
King cars but it's like that's what I'm
doing then my next two tours that I got
going on so I'm just moving when you and
uh can work on the joint project right
what is like the difference for you
creatively compared to working on like
your [ __ ]
[ __ ] like who takes the lead or does it
it ain't no lead is it different like
every song is different every song is
[ __ ] different and the difference
between like me working with Ken or
working by myself working with anybody
else is like bro that's my real partner
so it's like bro when I'm working with
this [ __ ] it ain't like we working we
in the studio playing the game smoking
weed what game are you guys playing 2K
Call of Duty fortnite whatever the [ __ ]
bro I've been sleeping at this [ __ ]
house and [ __ ] so it's like it's my real
bro who's better at 2K Ken for sure he's
the best ever I suck a 2K yeah facts
what's your team um 2K I can beat you
with any team any team well I'm talking
about like he's like YouTuber but I'm
like YouTube Five Call of Duty though oh
okay do you ever go on Twitch and watch
people play games yeah yeah all the time
I love video games I like music video
games and fashion and movies but I love
video games okay so what's your like all
time top five video game
Whatever video games ever ever it could
be any console come on Devil May Cry
great God damn Grand Theft Auto Max
Payne three okay
um dark game Uncharted all of them fire
PlayStation guy yeah and uh hmm I don't
know what I see in this
um
[Music]
so far you've got a lot of gas man I'm
gonna say Resident Evil I like Resident
Evils
which which was your favorite Resident
Evil I like two
and four two and three were crazy facts
when I was a little kid I had the first
one that was like my second or third
PlayStation game bro that [ __ ] scared
the [ __ ] out of me is playing that [ __ ]
now is just like the them games you got
I don't know you play that [ __ ] alone at
night that [ __ ] happens [ __ ] up it's
scary but it's a good vibe Metal Gear
Solid it's my [ __ ] better get silent
love that too ain't gonna lie play every
video game ever all of them even like
their games anime games whatever I
really did a little video game so you're
just a big gamer yo do you have a twitch
Channel
I had way before I started wrapping
that's what I would go do without like
that because he's getting a bag over
there yeah yeah him and T-Pain are just
[ __ ]
making Derek printing money playing
video games this is hard bro have you
done the thing where you like uh you
pretend what's it called role playing on
GTA no I haven't done it I don't have it
um you gotta like do that over the
computer like a desktop right yeah that
seems like too much work I've never
played games on a on a computer I want
to but I don't got the time right now
it's a lot of commitment I just need the
controller
they're pretty serious like if you break
character they shoot you yeah and then
they kick you out yep that's that's like
why would I do that when I have to live
a life in real life yeah yeah that's
fair